the Barbie movie sells itself as having
something for everybody but when it
comes to can that may not be entirely
true from silky smooth chests so the
meaning behind a beach off there's a lot
about Barbie's sidekick that only adults
will get
in director Greta gerwig's movie It's
Quickly established that Barbie has a
personal theme song of sorts the Indigo
Girls classic Closer To Fine Ken
initially seems content to sing that
song along with her but when he Ventures
out into the real world and discovers a
certain version of masculinity can no
longer like sasung at that point Ken
discovers his own favorite song and it
soon takes over as the anthem for Barbie
land's transition into kendam pushed by
the band of Matchbox 20. aside from
director Gerwig being a fan push was
lightly chosen because it sounds exactly
like the kind of song a dude bro would
be obsessed with and want to sing to a
woman he is trying to woo but those
already familiar with the song from its
mid 90s Heyday immediately realized
there was a lot more going on there with
lyrics like I want to take you for
granted the song gives us insight into
Ken's state of mind after all he had
previously felt taken advantage of by
Barbie so it makes sense that Kim would
like a song like push but it's Barbie
and Ken
there is no just Ken
well there seems to be at least a little
bit of body diversity among the Barbies
in the movie The kittens are all pretty
stereotypical and that they're uniformly
thin chiseled and completely devoid of
body hair it's most apparent to the two
main cans played by Ryan Gosling and
simu Leo given how often their bad
chests are visible but it can also be
seen or not seen on the arms and legs of
all the other cans there's no visible
hair on their bodies despite the fact
that some of these actors probably have
some body hair in real life sure enough
Leo confirmed to our Lord that he had to
have his body waxed two different times
while filming Barbie to ensure that
smooth hairless look but that's not all
that went into making the actors that
like human-sized kendalls Leo explained
to a law we had to look glossy and
plastic and there was a lot of body
paint applied every single day younger
viewers probably wouldn't have thought
twice about all that hairless skin
however those who have a few more years
on them suddenly find themselves
wondering how all these adult men could
look so smooth and shiny
Ken and Barbie are only in the real
world for about 10 seconds before Barbie
starts to experience what his light off
men openly gorg at her body and make
gross comments about it when the bear
encounter a group of construction
workers the workers start making a bunch
of inappropriate sexual remarks all of
which are directed a Barbie it's then
that Bobby explicitly tells them that
both XI and Ken are lacking in human
genitalia before that however Ken and
Barbie's inability to have sex has
hinted at in a hilariously awkward way
that probably Flew Over the heads of
younger audience members Barbies trying
to get Ken to go home so she can party
with the other Barbies and he asks if he
can stay the night she is confused and
inquires as to why he would want to
sleep over of course he doesn't have an
answer and ends up just as baffled about
why he even asked the question in the
first place later we had Barbie remarks
I'd like to see what smooth blob Ken's
packing in those shorts weird Bobby's
comment as further evidence that the
dolls have a vague sense of social
attraction to one another even though
they don't really know what to do with
it I'm coming with you okay Barbie and
Ken learn most of the same truths about
the real world only they absorb the
information in almost exactly opposite
ways Bobby is disappointed to see that
she hadn't fixed feminism and that the
world is in fact still a patriarchy
meanwhile Ken couldn't be more thrilled
to learn that there is a place where men
rule instead of women while exploring
Los Angeles on his own Ken stumbles into
a building where multiple screens are
showing visual representations of
masculinity throughout the years Kim
becomes especially fixated on one
recurring figure in that Montage
Sylvester Stallone after that Ken base
has much of what it means to be a man on
both Stallone himself and the character
he plays Rocky clearly makes a major
impression on him as Kenny seemed
wearing boxing gloves at one point when
he arrives back in Barbie land Ken's
obsession with horses as a sign of
masculinity could also be connected to
Rocky Balboa's nickname the Italian
Stallion but most obvious is a white fur
coat that Ken wears for a long stretch
of the movie which is modeled after a
similar coat that Stallone has seen
wearing in the Montage Stallone was
known to Don extravagant fur coats in
the 80s helping to popularize them as a
statement of not only hyper masculinity
but also wealth and success did you
bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
throughout some of the film Bobby is in
the real world searching for the girl
that's her adult Avatar belongs to
during her journey she and Ken end up at
a high school well Bobby confronts Sasha
and the school cafeteria Ken is left to
his own to explore the high school
before Longley finds his way to the
library it's there that he comes across
several fake but hilariously titled
books about the history of patriarchy
and other guy stuff the books have names
like the origins of patriarchy and man
Wars it's more than likely that those
books are meant to poke fun at Jordan
Peterson and other figures like him
Peterson's most famous book 12 rules of
life has been seen as Pro patriarchy and
he's been known to complain about how
masculinity is under attack in modern
society Peterson has also claimed that
people are afraid to admit that men hold
the power because in his view men are
simply better at being in charge there's
little doubt that Peterson would see the
changeover from Barbie land to kendem as
a step in the right direction it
wouldn't be the first time that a film
takes Peterson's ideals and Minds them
for villainy for one Olivia Wilde was
very upfront about the fact that
Peterson inspired Chris Pine's wretch of
the evil character in don't worry
darling
the opening scenes of Barbie show how
all the Barbies and Bobby land are BFFs
they all love each other respect each
other and celebrate each other's success
more that mostly seems true for the
Ken's as well Beach Ken and Taurus Ken
seems to have a pretty bitter rivalry
much of it stems from competing for the
attention of stereotypical Bobby but it
also seems like they simply don't like
each other very much how do you settle a
dispute in Barbie land well it's later
established that weapons don't exist
there moreover the kenstone exactly seem
like the type to get into vicious
physical altercations so it's suggested
that they have a beach off which sounds
innocent enough until phrases like this
start getting thrown around dude I would
beat you off right now Ken if I'll be
chat with you any day Ken sounds a
little like they are saying something
else doesn't it there are only a few
gags in Barbie that are meant to elicit
Chuckles from the adults while going
over the heads of children and the whole
concept of getting beached off is
perhaps the dirtiest of them all that
said having a snippet of it included in
some other trailers was definitely an
indication that a little bit of grown-up
naughtiness was going to be snug into
this PG-13 movie
in order to take Bobby land back from
the Cairns the Barbies have to be
reprogrammed back to their original
selves this way they're no longer the
meek subservient women that they've been
turned into in one of the movie's
funniest sequences some of the
reprogrammed Barbies pretend to need
reassurance about their looks or have
something mansplained to them the point
is so that no Kendall can resist giving
us full attention to them there are some
obvious ploys like the Barbie that
pretends she never saw the Godfather and
needs akin to explain the entire movie
to her leave the gun
thank you can only but one of the more
obscure ones as I can explaining the
role that Stephen malkmus played in the
evolution of rock and roll in relation
to Lou Reed and The Velvet Underground
most know read in his former band but
only those with a love of 90s Indie
music will recognize Malcolm X as a
front man for celebrated rap group
pavement pavement's biggest mainstream
success occurred in the early to mid 90s
and even then they never exactly lit up
the charts malkmus responded to the
shout out in an Instagram story
initially teasing that he was going to
get his lawyers involved but saying the
band is pro Greta goig so he seemed to
appreciate the mentioning of his name in
the movie
Bobby is absolutely jam-packed with
references to pop culture especially
films the films mentioned range from
Timeless Classics like The Wizard of Oz
all the way down to obscure films from
the French New Wave but there was one
scene in particular that is almost
entirely based on another sequence from
a different movie it's far beyond the
mere Easter egg or background reference
and instead is an outrise love letter to
the film that inspired it though the big
song and dance battle between the Kens
initially starts on the beach they are
all soon magically transported to a
dream-like space of Blues and pinks with
everyone dressed in black while some
have suggested that the outfits were
cool at Danny Zuko wears in much of
Greece the whole scene is a much more
obvious tribute to the iconic dream
ballet sequence From Singing in the Rain
released in 1952 the legendary Musical
predates both Ken and Barbie by a few
years and is certainly one of the oldest
pieces of Pop Culture history that Bobby
pays homage to
there have been a lot of different
variations of Barbie and Ken dolls over
the years longtime Barbie fans had a
blast trying to see how many different
dolls they recognized as characters in
the movie especially those that only had
a quick line or two or only appeared in
the background and said nothing at all
and Alan with a few exceptions almost
every Barbie and Ken mention in the
movie was a real dull at some point
remarkably this also includes the
canceled doll Sugar's Daddy can also
referenced and standing alongside a cat
in the movie is airing magic Ken who has
an even Wilder history the older viewers
surely remember upon his release in 1993
many were quick to identify that earring
magic Ken's clothing was clearly
inspired by the Fashions popular in the
gay club scene at the time as for the
ring the dull wore around its neck let's
just say that in addition to gaycan
earring magic cam was also sometimes
referred to as sea ring can
[Music]